bonjour romain vidal merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sur rt france
d'abord votre réaction avec par rapport
aux mesures qui ont été annoncées hier
le pass vaccinale pour le 15 janvier la
consommation interdite debout à partir
du 3 janvier votre avis sur ces mesures
oui nous avons vu les annonces qui
rajoute une chance ou les réflexions qui
ont été posées quelques semaines de cela
avec l'interdiction de pour danser dans
nos dans l'aube à réviser dans nos bars
et on peut dire musée puisqu'on fait
partie du patrimoine niveau de la france
mais façon parler c'est des mesures qui
sont très restrictifs qui vont être
punitive pour tout ce qui est barak a
fait et aussi la restauration
traditionnelle puisque comme vous avez
il ya les trois-quatre jours de
télétravail conseillé fortement je
conseillais par le gouvernement ce qui
fait fuir et qui fait et vite dans
certaines zones toute une population il
ya une déjeuner dans nos affaires et ça
ça tombe encore dans l'oeil toutes nos
affaires c'est très compliqué de
travailler dans ces conditions là le
pass sanitaire est un fait vacciner la
nourriture encore pour l'instant le
nombre de personnes qui peuvent venir
déjeuner dans nos affaires au dîner
d'affaires c'est très
une fermeture administrative
on en est pas encore très loin
il n'y a pas eu d'annoncé dead de la
part du gouvernement
votre réaction
c'est en cours de discussion d'après
discours de castex le premier ministre
hier comme quoi il ya les discussions
allaient se faire avec le ministre bruno
le maire nous l'appelons de nos voeux
nous demandons la remise en route des
êtres qu'on avait eue quand il y avait
quasiment les mêmes difficultés de
travail c'est à dire la consommation
debout interdite qui représente une
grosse part de chiffre d'affaires pour
les cafés bars brasseries
le télétravail fait fuir la clientèle
des restes de la restauration
traditionnelle
il faut peut-être ciblé mieux les aides
mais il faut des aides il faut le retour
en activité partielle avec une prise en
charge à 100 %
il faut un fond de vérité car dans la
restauration la marche n'est pas
importante donc déjà si chiffre
d'affaires n'est pas un pur quand la
marche l'est encore moins inexistante il
faut qu'on puisse repousser le béziers
le remboursement puisque normalement
nous serons dans quelques semaines
quelques mois devant ronces et impétueux
qui représente 25 % de notre chiffre
d'affaires annuel en plus de nos frais
courants ski strictement impossible
c'est un mur de dette que très peu de
restaurants auront affronté
donc il faut urgemment pouvoir mettre ça
repasse pour le mois de décembre et
janvier voire même sur toute la longueur
où il y aura une restriction sur notre
travail nous avons retrouvé une liberté
être
libre et remboursait toutes nos dettes
et sur les impacts à économique que vous
craignez
les impacts économiques ça fait déjà
plus de deux ans qu'on les cons les
crains qu'on les vit puisqu'on s'est
surendetté pour pouvoir faire ce verrou
nos affaires même si nous avons été
aidés par l'état n'oublions pas qu'une
bonne partie ce sont des dettes c'est le
pge le pge ainsi que d'autres dettes
puisque nous avons les empreintes avant
qu vide que nous devons en bourse est
souvent nous avons fait des
investissements dans nos affaires donc
l'impact économique est énorme ça fait
des années on vit dans une incertitude
avancer on avait eu les jaunes et les
retraites sur des régions comme paris ou
toulouse qui avait été catastrophique
pour nos affaires nous nous avons des
affaires qui sont de moins en moins
viable alors qu nous embaucherons
énormément de français qu'on recrute
constamment depuis des années des du
personnel c'est très très compliqué de
pouvoir dire qu'il n'est pas être facile
demain de pouvoir vivre de notre travail
est de voir faire survivre notre outil
de travail
vous avez dénoncé des mesures punitives
qu'est ce qu'il aurait fallu faire dans
la situation actuelle avec la menace du
variant omicron
alors je suis ni médecin ni politicien
n'est membre du gouvernement donc ça
serait compliqué de dire ce qu'il
fallait faire ce n'est pas ma place
je sais que nos bonnes choses qui ont
été faites au début il ya un
accompagnement qui a été fait
comme aucun pays presque n'a accompagné
certains de leurs établissements de leur
commerce qu'on avait été fermée
administrativement
remercie encore le gouvernement cet
accompagnement mais il ne faut pas nous
lâcher maintenant et encore continuer à
nous accompagner parce que les
restrictions qui nous ont été imposées
ne sont toujours par contre dire ce
qu'il faut faire ce n'est pas à moi de
le dire ni à une organisation
professionnelle faut ça pour qu'on
puisse travailler dans le calme dans la
sérénité ce qui n'est pas facile avec ce
qui nous attend est ce qu'on vit depuis
des années merci beaucoup à vous romain
vidal d'avoir été avec nous ce matin en
direct sur arte france rappelle que vous
êtes une secrétaire général du génie
paris ile de france